like to say that we're in your year five
of a two year process Washington DC is
one of the fastest growing economies in
the nation well except for Anacostia
located in southeast DC Anacostia has a
struggling local economy residents here
are in need of new retail believe it or
not one of the reasons Anacostia is so
depressed has to do with parking the
zoning right now does require parking
for every retail establishment the
zoning also requires that the parking be
on the property and that can be very
difficult for some of these properties
wait wait Anacostia is a pedestrian
neighborhood most people walk bus or
take the subway yet retailers are
required to build parking spaces that's
one of the most ludicrous regulations
that take place in an historic area
Duane gaudy air runs a non-profit in
Anacostia called arch development he
blames the obsolete parking regulations
for discouraging other retailers from
coming to the neighborhood no small
business is going to move into community
where they're constantly going to lose
money but there is good news the city is
planning to revise its half-century old
parking rules we're fairly far into the
process right now we're kind of like to
say that we're in your year five of a
two year process we've been out here
about 28 years they've been working on
the problem for 28 years hang in there
Anacostia it can't be that much longer